do you usually drink cups with two hands
I'm just curious
I don't mean that in any way I just it's
just honest question yeah I do
what is it I've
personally you're a one-hand guy I am a
one-hand guy yeah why do you just opt
for the two-hand method instead well I
saw Trump do it once drinking water he
used both hands I'm like that's a good
way to do it yeah yeah no I don't know
why but I just do okay it's none of your
business
that's it it's good to be here thank you
for coming yeah yeah um let me ask you
this your parents were are still
together they are you're you're not
correct how do you do this I could just
look at it no you are so innocent and
pure
[Music]